track down by yon protective Avenue
[Applause]
Wow just throws it and Victor just soars
to get that one I mean there are many
people that would be impressed with that
like victories because he'd know he had
to go get it what a terrific play and
switched it 15 seconds to play seven
here's a three by Oladipo Aldridge out
there shot clocks at five and going down
and he knocks it right down able to get
it over the top that's what you have
when you have Knuth you have
inconsistency with a back cut again I
mean look at this pass I pass it on the
money buddy hield
Willie cauley-stein coming just a good
read practices left he has two fouls
that's why he's out as Oladipo went you
can see the explosion I don't look
quickly until the other side of the rim
over Anthony Davis who came late Victor
Oladipo was able to finish strong like
his hand was on the rim Oladipo gets
inside and scores pushed it all the way
back with 6.5 seconds as point for lost
it in on the dribble he was tilted out
to create something in there nothing
there
good anticipation by Victor
[Applause]
get some great help here you see an
athlete Victor throws it down nice and
easy I have a feeling Quinn we're gonna
go break last year now in his first year
here in Memphis all the V PO beats
Brooks into the half court puts it up
yeah bass has had a lot of good offense
going in that first half after all the
Depot goes coast to coast and buries the
shot professor and the Pacers have a
double figure halftime lead in Memphis a
20-point 10:00 a.m. tomorrow morning
tickets start at just five dollars
available for Friday's game versus
Toronto check out all the details on
gold Friday at Pacers dot-com good read
here watch the bonus bounce pass one
hand mix strong finish there by Oladipo
Depot leads the break as hit two threes
finds Turner bounces oh what a great
no-look
but that yog but got a [ __ ] at Collison
family time shot clock and Lewis
oh the steel
here's all the teeth Mahan for the lead
the San Antonio Spurs comes up when the
loose ball
one of the best in the league early in
transition threes and the Pacers with
30.1 to play lead 97 96 headed his
career all pac-12 then we were skin here
Zola - bouncing - indeed on a great cup
they have their largest lead
they never led in the first half all the
Depot has 28 and the Pacers lead at 88
80 Bahts until the vision hook with
primer rings little speculative to run
away from the television here's three
seconds Oladipo for three a of the paint
honors will take the lead
oh that's that's a very unusual thing to
do Chris
they have great confidence in his Smith
block by the Oladipo
that's he's not even into play that
comes
the patient's push it up
that's a hiccup with the fruits of what
in the first half he was found on a
three-point shot
mr. Reid you can see that this is
planned and maybe there's eye contact
made and you just throw it at the rim
and let Victor Oladipo get it but last
rules that right where it leaves to be
got 17 Middleton has 19 two seconds one
second Oladipo at the buzzer that's what
he's on the ability to good feels
cleared space these guys are good to
fits late you got I know that's why you
gotta move the ball gets inside what a
shot by Vic I'm telling
some self-assured but I didn't think he
it
gets it up off the glass nicely actually
3d
it comes back over the head right-handed
off the glass battles on white side
that's his fourth
[Music]
it's the third team foul against the
heat you have won three straight at home
after nine straight home losses the deep
thought you can make victories it and
then it gets a jam for a strong finish
make them pay [ __ ] we had that
fortunately has been a challenge for the
Pacers to score to put their defenses
victus working on this show me
he made an all-star game and continued
their offense and defense faces thrown
and he didn't get hit I mean if you
gotta hit that heart you're right that
face was able to turn right away there's
not much you do here
[Applause]
Walker minutes neva right here what's
coming and he knew that whether you who
got his milestone is going to be people
he's damned that that was gold anything
I don't know about that
I'm the triple double in his first
career start bullet Depot the steel
racing against it on it with a
left-handed 7 nothing run the first time
all-star six 3s the Knicks have made
five
nice job by Victor Oladipo he won't get
a steal but he'll get the dunk running
on a nice 360 this is just so unselfish
play and then Lance puts on a little bit
of the show as he's preparing for the
all-star game dunk contest
you might see that one these are still
have time with six to shoot
[Applause]
yeah you can see that
coming this is good office got a
mismatch makes you you can get it up
quickly he gets it up when I'll Quinn
with a strong finish with that right
hand Victor's having himself some kind
of games arm and when you tell you what
people are not talking about the second
half as though a deep ball comes up with
this deal remember dunk contest
the black panther Mastan with the black
panther man come aft and Ally three from
Turner
short Barabbas and the rebound yeah he
didn't see this yeah pardon I wasn't
sure he saw the difference behind him
with a Pacers number four Indiana by
team the scored off the right side
I watched over seller just big fella you
take that home with you and it's a tough
shot a mini strategy a three-point shot
she had made oh he threw it through the
legs of Middleton a35 Donovan
[Applause]
you'll see right there gets it through
their paces get a three-pointer on up
get a little bit of run here of seven
they'e Thomas started Tula because he
CDs was very good defensive player on
the depo raises up and hits the jumper
when he's a beast
I've done
let's face the gun down that shot 16 of
24 including 5 of 11 from three-point
range
another look at Victor Oladipo the first
time all-star his second field goal
he's got more but as we go to break the
Lakers put 37 up and they lead by 8
after one Randle again shop everybody
don't stand hold it
McDonough [ __ ] goes you'll see radiant
trailing is older deep hole but he's in
the conversation for MVP Thomason
they'll get it away
[Applause]
holiday is the one guy that commits
great blood by control of people at the
real Comic Con
as you can see holiday is there that's
going up yeah you can you can make an
argument either way that may be going up
is it yeah that's going
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Victor Oladipo we will everybody knows
you're the guy on the team that should
take the shot
Victor's able of clear space and knock
it down you can see the 0e jumbo jack
when you miss two free throws that's
what the cheer was about what about good
defense Depot there's Kylie Stan was
going for the strong strong finish
partner I mean Victor just times that to
a tee because at some point you got to
bring it to ten feet to get it over the
rim and Victor times times it when
cauley-stein had to bring it that's the
summit meeting looking for the Pacers
this year what's terrific ball handling
man oh my goodness shake him up bit sick
of my oh excuse me Oh take that with you
in a little coupe bye Victor is not the
four shots and she said Victor's off to
a great start he could shoot any time he
wants almost oh what a shot by Oladipo
he has 21 here Victor does a nice job
faking getting to the rim and with
Dwight Howard trying to be out there
where the screen is at that point
there's nobody that can block the shot
Williams can only watch on James
stolen by Oladipo Stevenson back to
Oladipo
[Applause]
[Music]
actually Stevenson stays in the game so
Oladipo hold have to get rid of it with
the shot clock expiring
[Music]
Oladipo
attacking and finishing over the top
here
just blow but blows by JR Smith no help
and finishes knock clock at four Oladipo
harassed by James
Oladipo pulls back high-arcing please Oh
we knocks it down as the shot clock
expires and a big smile from Oladipo
nine seconds two on the shot clock
this ball got it blocked big guy just
stood there
TJ leaf and he backs in a three-pointer
before the buzzer one more time as
Oladipo just throws it up and prays
extra pass in the corner shot clock down
to three but Donovan spikes us all
movement they're good patience really
good patience that you want to look at
we talked about in the open shock locket
Judith big a big hit was there because
man's came out when Victor showed it at
first
the depot they did not use a timeout and
it was Oladipo over al horford
Depot behind that screen now has a
switch in his bag on one bead and bead
moving his feet you can't stop Oladipo
right now a tough cover for him all of
your pants the beach shuffle pass inside
and young caps it off with a layup
Brett Brown will use his final timeout
I got them this much I'm gonna cross and
go and then a pinpoint pass he's done
that time and time again here in the
last six minutes of this game see he has
great vision and he's not going to force
his shot and Oladipo wants it again
approaching two minutes to play ways and
that's what happened didn't what he does
and then kook's gets there but he gets
there and time for a face show a little
poster ax shake him up you see market
and had the clearest spacing by the time
Hutchinson came it was nothing but up
punch by big left handed and now with
five seconds here's Oladipo three
seconds we saw a threesome win it
raise up a little bit
fifty deep way to raise up they huge
overtime three but they send miles away
because they don't want to TT which is
good because Nate McMillan did that and
right here victus backs him up suits a
little long dance out of the rotation
until the recent road trip but he's
played the last three games and played
eight ball
how about fat first my goodness depo
takes about 37% of his shots from three
if I'm guarding him though I am still
down in a stick ants do not stand up
mario hezonia cuz he's got this kind of
burst
[Applause]